all right guys welcome this is going to
be a tutorial on how to
uh add add-ons into mozilla thunderbird
the email client
so first thing you want to do is open up
a web browser i recommend firefox for
this particular
operation i've found an add-on for
thunderbird that i like so what i'm
going to do it has
these instructions here
right click it
and hit save link as so
save link as
and pick anywhere i guess uh marcus
downloads
and i'll just say
mestology
there it is it's done downloading
scanning for viruses it's done
so once that is done you can exit your
web browser
and go ahead and open your email client
thunderbird
first thing you're going to do is go to
tools and add-ons it's not going to be
there instantly
and you're gonna hit the install button
from here
you can search marcus
and downloads where'd it go
and find exactly what you just
downloaded this one and hit open
and you can
install straight from there i actually
don't like installing this one so i'll
hit cancel
but it'll install it right into
thunderbird it'll integrate the whole
thing
and soon enough you will have
you'll just restart thunderbird once at
the most twice
and thunderbird will be back up and
working and it will have all your
add-ons i even have this calendar add-on
here right on my events oh i've already
used it quite a bit tasks up in here
so i got a lot going on um i've got i'll
show you what add-ons i do have
lightning which is the integrated
calendar tasks that i showed you
the minimize tray which is works when i
just minimize thunderbird it's not down
here
it is
here and i double click it to bring it
back up
i have
talkback which sends information about
well that came with it so it's not
important
thunderbrowse which adds the web
browsing feature to thunderbird and i'll
show you that real quick
here it is
google
logo thunderbird atoms
it's relatively fast
so
those are
how you uh basically that's how you add
add-ons to thunderbird nothing to it
thanks for watching my video
subscribe